this might be one of the weirdest things
i've used yet it's gonna be a really
long day oh god
we're not calling it hot putting a tuna
in a jar i mean this looks crazy
wow oh no i'm speechless increasingly
weird
is this the craziest thing i've ever
done i think so
i'm alexis and i'm a chef who's always
up for a challenge
today the internet has chosen a random
appliance for me to make a three-course
meal out of
let's see what we have in store
[Music]
i have no idea what this is
um okay it's a wax warmer i
also don't know what that is what does
one do with a wax warmer
[Music]
i'm gonna need to do some research i'm
gonna be honest i'm not feeling great
i know you can melt stuff i know there's
some possibilities but i'm just
really skeptical about how warm or hot
this is gonna get
we're trying to cook a meal here come on
there's
this woman on tik tok bunny birdie gator
who uses a tea light to like cook and do
things with
you know these are electric it's a
little different i've been so graciously
given
two jars this is where the candle goes
this is where wax goes
i think for you know ease of cooking
it's gonna make sense to put the jar
directly onto the
cooktop let's call it a cooktop for now
confidence level
one i mean i guess i just have to get
started
wish me luck i'm starting with my
appetizer today which is tomato comfy
over burrata
tomato confit is usually done at like
275
300 degrees fahrenheit this according to
my research only gets to
110 degrees so we'll see what happens
i like doing this with tomatoes and
putting it like over pasta you can put
it on bread it's like
unbelievably good okay so oops i'm just
gonna pour olive oil over the tomatoes
so that they're fully submerged and you
can add
any aromatics you want and some salt of
course
add some pepper got some very stubborn
garlic
some thyme okay so i think the tomatoes
are ready to go
okay turn it on okay the lights are on
confidence level like one i mean this is
warm
i guess you could warm your like tea or
coffee on it can't really make that a
meal
oh god i guess i mean i don't know this
is feeling warmer
i guess we'll just see see you in many
hours my little
confi moving on onto my tuna samin
nostrout who wrote salt fat acid heat
does this amazing olive oil poached tuna
and so i thought i'd kind of mimic that
with the candle warmer i'm gonna try
doing the whole thing in this jar
obviously the tuna is uh bigger than the
jar so i think i need to cut it down
add some salt what am i doing this is so
weird
just put in tuna jar
we're just gonna put some olive oil
again to cover it
and some peppercorns maybe a bay leaf or
two
dried pepper that looks fine let me just
check
wow okay this is not even warm
like there's no heat okay i think i'm
gonna cover this in tin foil you know i
see these little holes and i think some
heat could be escaping here
some heat it's like a pathetic amount of
heat
but maybe if i kind of like wrap the
whole thing in foil
i think i should do the same with the
tuna it's very graceful right
look at that okay so i think i should
also enclose the whole thing
like a tin foil tent you know as i use
this entire roll of tin foil i think my
confidence
is like just like we're just plummeting
i mean this looks crazy
well we're done we made a meal
i'm just gonna let those go for a really
long time
okay moving on to the chocolate so i'm
just going to add the chocolate chips
directly to the little wax pot chocolate
melts at body temperature this gets
hotter than body temperature
it's going to work we've got some fun
freeze dried raspberries cacao nibs
slicky sea salt it's gonna be pretty
in about two hours
you guys i have big news and that is
that the chocolate
has started to melt i would say my
confidence is at a three
okay let's check in on these guys
tuna is feeling warm at the base
but has a long way to go oh my god okay
waiting
for that second look at that wow
wow okay all the chocolate chips have
melted
i'm gonna put it on my parchment paper
i'm just gonna spread it
okay i think that looks great and do the
same thing with the white chocolate i
feel like i don't need that much because
i just want to do like a little design
so i think it'll go faster
i want to do one of those designs where
you like do the lines of white chocolate
over and then use a skewer
toothpick something like that to make
those like
you'll see i think my confidence for the
chocolate part
is steadily rising wow
oh okay this is like definitely not what
i envisioned but that's okay
oh no that's not good uh so the
chocolate seemed to have hardened a bit
too much before i put the white on so it
just drew a line
which is not division but you know
that's okay i'm just going to do
something
maybe we can like do some white it's
going to like abstract
bark oh no oh oh god
oh god it's a pollock
it's like a jackson pollock chocolate
bark it's all the rage
because the chocolate is already
hardened i think i need to warm it back
up
on the warmer let's get in like
increasingly weird also again don't do
this at home this feels like
a fire hazard
oh oh okay okay okay yep yep this is a
great idea okay
starting yeah okay maybe i can do some
of the raspberries
okay oh it's such a delicate process
okay oh god oh god oh no
oh no it's melting very fast now okay
and some flaky sea salt
you know i think i'm gonna just stop
while i'm ahead here it's not my
finest work but i think it'll totally
totally do i'm gonna let this harden and
then i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna wait for a while back
with the thermometer i'm gonna check on
things
let's start with the tomatoes it smells
amazing let's see what the temp is oh
i'm honestly
shocked right now oh my god 145
okay it's still about half the
temperature
it would need to be if i was doing this
in the oven but
that's okay just using this as a spoon
it turns out
um yeah tomatoes they might be warmed
but raw
i'm gonna try one it is a bit softer
another hour two this might actually be
something
feeling a lot better but i think i just
need to be patient
my confidence about these tomatoes right
now is like
a six goodbye okay
now the tuna
look at that look at that it looks like
something's happening here
i would say it's cooking it's poaching
oh that's that's raw okay the tuna is at
about 100 degrees
i i mean honestly i don't know if this
is gonna cook through this might be like
the first time
that like i don't really have anything
to deliver i'm feeling confidence on the
tuna right now it's like a three
i'll take a three and you just wait you
know i think of all the things i've
tried to poach over
this crazy show the tuna is the hardest
tuna in a candle warmer takes the cake
while i'm waiting for the tomato confit
and the tuna to
you know do their thing i thought i
could start on the fennel salad the idea
is that this fennel salad is going to go
along with the tuna
i want to save the fronds they're
totally edible and just
slice the core out got a mandolin here
these are
super super super super dangerous so if
you're using one at home
make sure you have a napkin or like one
of those little glove guards
with a mandolin don't be a hero if you
can't get this it's fine let it go
this fennel salad super simple shave
fennel
salt pepper lemon zest lemon juice
fennel fronds
i'm gonna add a little bit of parm too
some saltiness to bounce out the acidity
and the crunch
oops this is a snack piece you have for
yourself
i think i should just check this and see
how it's going
whoa you guys it's working
wow that is so crazy
i'm speechless 118.
i kind of think i should take it out and
like see what happens oh this is weird
huh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i deserve like a trophy a gold medal an
award
like there's maybe should be like a
shrine a statue
like i just cooked tuna over a candle
warmer
and it's delicious i'm so proud of
myself this is crazy is this the
craziest thing i've ever done i think so
yeah hey
i'm really proud of myself i think i can
plate this i mean it looks gray
it looks gray little bit of palm the
fronds
pepper salt
[Music]
amazing it's amazing i realize there's
still more to do but this is amazing
i'm gonna put this off to the side and
assess the tomato comfy situation
okay i'm feeling so excited i'm feeling
so jazzed i feel super confident
like if the two it's just let's just see
look at that like
if look at that here this is for
comparison
i i mean it's amazing
this day has been a roller coaster so i
think i can plate this
burrata i'm just gonna open it oh my god
it's gonna be so good
look at that look look at that one look
at that one that is like
fully soft no tomato left behind here
i'm flabbergasted
i'm gonna do like a little bit of
balsamic
it's a little more than i planned on
some pepper let's just go
crazy it's just for me some salt okay
some basil
yum we love basil you guys
burrata tomato confit it looks
incredible it smells
even better i feel i'm like a flying
high i'm like back i'm a 10.
this is great this is so cute it's
rustic which i think is the point of
chocolate bark
and like it's it's adorable look at look
it's adorable i almost don't want to
break it but here we go oh my god little
pile of chocolate bar
just for me oh my god oh my god i mean
have you ever seen something cuter than
this tiny tiny little personal plate of
chocolate bar
made on a candle warmer i think it's
taste test time when i started today i
honestly thought i was gonna have
nothing to serve but chocolate bark so
the fact that there's like a
full meal is blowing my mind
it's beautiful like this is it's
beautiful
i would serve this at a dinner party
maybe not from a candle warmer i've just
been waiting for the burrata
i mean it's amazing the tomatoes are
perfect the oil all around infused it's
so good i feel emotional i feel like i
could cry like that is so
good to the tuna
it's delicious i'm so impressed with
myself
like the tuna is actually so good it's
lovely it's blowing my mind this is so
i mean i'm i'm like a broken record it's
so good
it's so good i mean chocolate bark how
can this be bad it's
gorgeous it's cute it's beautiful it's
chocolate
the combination incredible this is
amazing
this could be one of the best meals i've
made 10 out of 10.
this has been amazing let me know in the
comments what you
would make on a candle warmer see you
next time bye guys
[Music]
you